Traductor: Paula Motter
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En la antigua Grecia, la cefalea
era considerada una seria dolencia.
En busca de alivio, las víctimas acudían
a Asclepio, el dios de la medicina.
Y si el dolor continuaba,
un médico recurría
a la práctica más conocida:
hacer una pequeña perforación en el cráneo
para drenar sangre
supuestamente infectada.
Esta técnica tan atroz,
llamada trepanación,
solía reemplazar la cefalea
por un trastorno más permanente.
Por suerte, los médicos no recurren
hoy a esas herramientas
para curar la cefalea.
Pero aún queda mucho por conocer
de esta antigua dolencia.
Actualmente, las cefaleas
se dividen en dos grupos:
cefaleas primarias
y cefaleas secundarias.
Las primarias no responden a síntomas
de otra enfermedad, lesión ni trastorno;
son la dolencia en sí mismas.
Pero enseguida volveremos a este tema,
porque si bien las cefaleas primarias
corresponden al 50 %
de los casos registrados,
hay en realidad más información
sobre las cefaleas secundarias.
Este tipo de cefaleas se origina
en otros problemas de salud,
y pueden ocurrir por deshidratación,
abstinencia de cafeína,
lesión en cabeza y cuello
o enfermedades cardíacas.
Los médicos han clasificado
más de 150 tipos diagnosticables,
todos de diferentes causas,
síntomas y tratamientos posibles.
Pero tomemos de ejemplo
un caso común: la sinusitis.
Los senos paranasales
son un sistema de cavidades
que se encuentran detrás
de la frente, la nariz y los pómulos.
Cuando los senos paranasales
se infectan,
nuestra respuesta inmunológica
eleva la temperatura en esa zona,
somete las bacterias al calor
e inflama las cavidades,
que adoptan un tamaño
muy superior al normal.
Los senos paranasales hinchados oprimen
las arterias y las venas craneales,
y también los músculos
de la cabeza y el cuello.
Allí, los receptores del dolor,
llamados nociceptores,
se activan ante este estímulo
e inducen al cerebro a liberar
un flujo de neuropéptidos
que inflaman
los vasos sanguíneos craneales
causando sensación de hinchazón
y calor en la cabeza.
Este malestar, junto con los músculos
hipersensitivos de la cabeza,
son responsables del dolor molesto
y punzante, típico de la cefalea.
El dolor de las cefaleas no siempre
se produce por inflamación.
La tensión muscular y la inflamación
de los nervios sensitivos
provocan distintos grados
de malestar en cada cefalea.
Pero todos los casos responden
a algún agente irritante craneal.
Si bien la causa es conocida
en las cefaleas secundarias,
aún se ignora el origen
de las cefaleas primarias.
Los científicos siguen investigando
los potenciales desencadenantes
de los tres tipos de cefaleas primarias:
las migrañas recurrentes y prolongadas;
las cefaleas en racimos,
de dolor agudo y repentino;
y las cefaleas tensionales,
que son las más comunes.
Como su nombre lo indica,
las cefaleas tensionales
nos dan la sensación
de tener una banda apretada
alrededor de la cabeza.
Estas cefaleas aumentan la sensibilidad
de los músculos pericraneales,
que empiezan a producir dolor
al latir con la sangre y el oxígeno.
Según los pacientes, los disparadores
pueden ser el estrés,
la deshidratación
y los cambios hormonales;
sin embargo, estas causas no se condicen
del todo con los síntomas.
Por ejemplo, en las cefaleas
por deshidratación,
el lóbulo frontal se contrae
dentro del cráneo,
produciendo inflamación en la frente,
lo cual no coincide con la ubicación
del dolor en las cefaleas tensionales.
Los científicos manejan algunas teorías
sobre las causas reales de la cefalea,
desde el espasmo de vasos sanguíneos
hasta la hipersensibilidad
de los nociceptores,
pero se las desconoce a ciencia cierta.
Mientras tanto, la mayoría de los estudios
se centran en las cefaleas
primarias más agudas.
Las migrañas son cefaleas recurrentes,
que producen una sensación
de opresión en el cráneo
y puede durar de cuatro horas a tres días.
En el 20 % de los casos,
estos ataques son tan intensos
que pueden sobrecargar el cerebro
de energía eléctrica,
y así sobreexcitar las terminales
nerviosas de los nervios sensitivos.
Esto produce alucinaciones llamadas auras,
que pueden incluir la visión de luces
intermitentes y esquemas geométricos,
y una sensación de hormigueo.
Las cefaleas en racimos, que son
otro tipo de cefalea primaria,
producen ardor y dolor punzante
detrás de un ojo,
ocasionando enrojecimiento ocular,
contracción de la pupila
y caída del párpado.
¿Qué puede hacerse con estos trastornos
que afectan drásticamente
la calidad de vida de tanta gente?
Las cefaleas tensionales
y la mayoría de los casos secundarios
pueden tratarse con calmantes
de venta libre,
como las drogas antiinflamatorias
que reducen la inflamación craneal.
Y muchos disparadores
secundarios de la cefalea,
como la deshidratación,
la fatiga ocular,
y el estrés,
pueden ser evitados de manera preventiva.
Las migrañas y las cefaleas en racimos
son más complejas,
y aún no se han descubierto
tratamientos confiables
efectivos para todas las personas.
Pero, por suerte, los farmacólogos
y neurólogos trabajan con gran esmero
para desentrañar los apremiantes misterios
que nos dan tanto dolor de cabeza.